and joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right now is the
starting quarterback of the philadelphia
eagles getting set to take on the
cowboys on monday night football
um to wrap up week number three in a big
nfc east contest first place online he
is jalen hurts for the philadelphia
eagles how are you jalen
i'm doing well i'm blessed i'm blessed
how you doing i am doing better for
talking to you uh it's been a while last
time you and i spoke
was uh right before the nfl draft
and i asked you
what a team would be getting if they
drafted you and you said they'd be
getting a dog
and now here you are as the top dog of
the philadelphia eagles and i'm
wondering
how things are different for you this
year
than last for you
jalen yeah you know you go through so
many changes from year to year
and
the success of a football team is
measured upon how you respond to those
changes
and you know we've got a new coach in
and
um everybody's bought in to the values
he's brought in and the principles that
he presents daily
and we we've bought in and committed to
one another as a team so
um
we've gotten out to the start we've
gotten out too and we we've learned a
lot about ourselves in two games so i'm
excited to go out there on monday night
and um
have another week at it with my
teammates what have you learned about
yourselves in two games
then
we're learning that you know
we got a lot of great players
got a lot of great players um we have
great coaches and i think
you know we
it's just a matter of consistently being
on the same page and everything that we
do
so we go out there and do that um
great thing
so when you said that you're you're
buying what the coach is selling what is
exactly is nick ciriani selling he's
kind of a big unknown for many of us in
the national media and folks in
philadelphia just getting to learn who
he is and what his personality is what
has he sold to you that you say the
team's already buying in 2020 the
confidence the confidence we have in
coaching
and what he brings i mean from day one
um
he brought a great energy and he brought
great fundamentals you know talking
about accountability and
and holding everyone on the team to that
um talking about the importance of
football iq and knowing what you're
supposed to do with
the technical side of the sport and
scheme
um
talking about being disciplined talking
about connecting with one another
talking about all these important things
that go into um you know having a
successful run a good run at this
and uh are you just saying that about
the coach because he's wearing a t-shirt
with your photograph on it is that why
jim
i guess we built a good enough
relationship for him to do that
did you know he was gonna start
did you know he was gonna wear a t-shirt
with your your picture on it your face
on it well you know one day he brought
it into
the day before actually i guess he wore
it you know fans send stuff in all the
time
and um
you know from day one he told us he's
like you know y'all send me
you know shirts of your college or
you know whatever i support you guys do
whatever so you know you see him
wear kelsey's third shirts you know jake
elliott
uh bg and then i guess it was my turn
and um someone ended up sending him a
really cool shirt really cool shirt and
he ended up wearing it so that was cool
well i mean you know it is just a shirt
right but i think personally it's more
than a shirt it really is to have your
coach
step up
meeting the media in a t-shirt with your
face on it
and uh certainly since you've been so
you've been through so much man in your
playing life you know from colleges
to
this situation in philadelphia where
you're now the starter what did it mean
for you to see
a head coach
wearing a t-shirt with your face on it
you're the starting quarterback in
philadelphia for the
eagles i mean you said it you said it
it's a representation of so much more um
and it simply shows the church that he
has in me and
um the support he has in me and i want
to i want to prove him right i'm going
to prep prove everybody in philadelphia
right
you know and
and do that so just want to go out there
and win games and then
jaylen hurts philadelphia eagles
quarterback here on the rich eisen show
uh prior to
monday night football uh and
i've been reading this i've been really
wanted to talk to you for a while jalen
cause the last time you played a
nationally televised game you didn't
finish it and it was a big contest in
the nfc east and the whole country was
watching because it was the last game of
the year and there was so much on the
line
what what did happen
that night where you got pulled from
that game taken out of that game jalen
hurts yeah i've moved i've moved on from
it you know
it
is no point of me talking about it i
mean it's in the past um you know we're
off to this monday night football game
my first monday night football game
looking forward to that and so let me
just ask one last one i'll take one last
crack at it did you say something
to management or anything after that
game certainly when there was a new
coach coming in did you bring it up to
him like hey i'm the quarterback here
any anything like that jalen hurts
from that i'm not going i'm not gonna
talk about none of it okay um then let
me ask you this question then now that
we're here in 2021
and you're getting ready for the dallas
cowboys and dak prescott and you've seen
what he's been able to do coming back
and you obviously have gotten
uh through a lot in your journey what do
you think this monday night matchup
means
for you
versus dak and the whole country
watching on monday night
not not really a personal thing
um just a game a game um we opportunity
guard to even win if we if we go out
there and handle our business so
you know
dallas is a great team and have a great
defense um great offense and great
quarterback so we got to be ready to
play what expected specifically about
this defense jalen hurts
are you are you looking at film that
you've been talking about all week long
what is the challenge for you
specifically
on monday night in dallas they got a
defense that's going to fly to the ball
um
great cover guys in the back end and
they they've created a lot of turnovers
so
we just have to
execute at a high level offensively and
how how has it been to be with devonta
smith
for you to be have a connection with the
first
overall drafted uh first rookie uh first
round draft pick rookie for the eagles
and you obviously have a history
together what's that been like for you
it's been great it's been great um great
conversations
he has a thorough
you know eagerness to
learn
um
always trying to learn more and trying
to get on the same page with me
and we're all in this for one thing
that's to win
we all want to win and um we're trying
to do anything and everything to get on
the same page so we can do that
and play on a high level so he's been
very helpful he's he's a dog out there
okay and you know what's what has it
been for you to walk around this
building and know that you're the
starting quarterback of the philadelphia
eagles beginning of a season
and and what has that been like for you
jalen for your experience and how you've
been able to
uh feed off of that potentially and have
um an aura that that you're able to give
out as a leader which i know you have
built into your system what's that like
for you
i don't think my position i'm out on
any uh identification or
you know
classification made elsewhere has
deterred me from being who i am you know
i try and go into it with the regardless
of the situation
and and be me um and
that's a guy that's going to lead go
play hard and go out there and make
plays so
um i just want to represent my team in
the best way i can and impact them in a
positive way
um you know the beauty of football is
it's a great sport
because
we uplift each other we're there for
each other um we have each other's backs
um
we show love and um empathy to one
another so it's the ultimate team sport
we're all in this thing together um
that's what i love about it and i love i
love that too what do you mean by you
you're empathetic to each other
i love that what do you mean by that we
got each other's backs we got it we've
got each other's backs
um through any and everything you know
we put so much work in together um
daily we're here all day together
you know you got some guys that
you know don't don't go home until late
at night and have kids you don't get to
spend that amount of time they would
love to coach is the same
so
um
we all feel for that we feel for another
another and that makes us so much more
special on game days because
um
we're playing for one another in
in every way a few more minutes left
with jalen hurts getting ready for
monday night football football against
the dallas cowboys do you feel like
you're playing for your starters job
still in philadelphia despite being told
i know we've established thought this
entire conversation the job's yours the
coaches got your photograph on a t-shirt
but do you feel like this is a this is
your one opportunity this 17-game season
regular season and if you're fortunate
more
to prove that you can be the guy in
philadelphia you are the guy is that
happening for you jalen
yeah i want to make it bigger than what
it is you know every day is an
opportunity for me
i mean i i just want to go out there and
play the high level and win games
nothing else really matters nothing else
really matters to me
jalen hurts here uh getting ready for
monday night football all right jalen
not to put any extra pressure on you but
you are the starting quarterback of my
fantasy league jalen um
and uh the team is called maybe maybe
maybe me being your starting quarterback
in your fantasy league says a lot to all
those other questions you asked yeah
well i mean yes i i i no uh i'm i'm i'm
a professional jalen just like you
uh i'm currently trying to make plays in
this interview just like you make plays
you know in in your profession um
and uh no i believe means that if i had
a t-shirt with your face on it i would
wear it as well i'm not that's not
looking for anything free from you i'm
just saying that uh it's pretty big for
me this weekend that the team is called
you donkeys because it's with my poker
buddies and they're a bunch of donkeys
and um and i kind of need the w i'm not
gonna lie just putting the pressure on
for monday night football uh i just flat
out telling you go go do your thing
jalen it's more than just a game is what
i'm saying to you
absolutely absolutely
all right
it does indeed make diamonds and
hopefully uh it'll make some diamonds
for you as well jalen i appreciate
catching up with you thanks for the time
best of luck and let's uh let's talk
down the line this season
most definitely are we good talking to
you right back at you right back at you
at jalen hurts on both twitter and
instagram jalen hurts philadelphia
eagles quarterback prior to monday night
football against dak prescott and the
dallas cowboys hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here